The answer is Jonathan grows 50 pixels on each side. Let's see how I figured
that out. We're back where we left off in BlueJ. I'm calling the grill method
on the picture of Jonathan and passing 50 and 50, but I'm going to cancel that
for a moment. Out of curiosity, what is the current width of this picture? Get
width. It looks like it's 185. So now, if I call the grow method, like I was
going to do before, Jonathan just got bigger. But how much exactly? It's hard
to tell whether he grew 50% bigger or 50 pixels on each side bigger? Or, just
50 pixels wider and 50 pixels taller. So, let's check the width again. Get
width, and now it's 285. So, it looks like the width grew by 100 pixels. If it
were going to grow by 50%, it would probably have grown by about 190 pixels.
So, it sounds to me like it grew 50 pixels this way and 50 pixels this way, and
then did the same up and down.